Turkish forces in their Syrian rebel
allies attack Kurdish positions in
northeastern Syria pounding them with
airstrikes and artillery barrages in a
cross-border military operation just
days after US troops pulled back from
the area world leaders have described
the offensive as dangerous and reckless
and warned it will threaten regional
stability
the Turkish vice president sees it
differently why this operation will be a
source of peace and will bring peace and
will sort out the Syrian crisis in a
radical way this operation led by
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan is one of
the steps and one of the procedures
among other steps taken by President
Erdogan for the sake of Syria and for
keeping the unity of Syria turkish
president received tape rawand
says the aim of the offensive is to
eliminate what he calls a terror
corridor along turkey's southern border
he also wants to establish a safe zone
inside territory currently held by the
Kurdish led Syrian democratic forces
where two million refugees currently
hosted in Turkey can be settled the SDF
says the offensive has caused widespread
panic evacuations and will trigger a new
humanitarian crisis we saw two tanks in
front of our village so we left fearing
that our children might get hurt
following the shelling of the village
most residents have left but some young
men have stayed
the Kurds have been key players in the
fight against ISIL in Syria the SDF have
appealed to the United States and its
allies to establish a no-fly zone to
protect it from Turkish attacks turkey
is trying Fruity to tax to open new
lands for the mercenary to die ich it is
trying to lengthen the life of these
groups we do not grieve any attacks by
turkey and those supporting them the
world knows the reason behind the attack
on the northeast of Syria the Turkish
government describes the main fighting
force in the SDF as a terrorist
organization linked to the outlawed
Kurdistan Workers Party the pink KK
which is fought against the Turkish
government for decades oh no one sees
this military operation as a chance to
weaken an old enemy but the
international community is worried about
the prospect of more suffering for the
people of northern Syria as well as the
security implications of this move
Turkey has so far offered a no clear
plan about how to deal with thousands of
jailed ISIL fighters on the Syrian side
of the border
the Turkish Defense Ministry says a
ground incursion into Syria has begun
and there are rising fears for the
hundreds of thousands of civilians
living close to the border many of whom
fled to SDF controlled territory for
safety in a country that has already
suffered years of war chants trafford al
Jazeera on the turkish-syrian border